Religiously.
I want to believe people are
fundamentally good.
Um,
yeah,
I think people are a,
I think people are fundamentally good.
And B,
I think people are fundamentally,
um,
humorous and people fundamentally want
to laugh.
And you know,
if someone is not laughing,
that's the exception.
That's perversion because I think you
can be turned from someone who likes to
laugh to someone who doesn't.
But I think it's almost impossible to go
the other way.
I don't think no one's ever met a
humorless person who became a funny one.
Yeah.
Now
you can learn the form and whatever,
and maybe you could even learn the form
so well that you can fool most people.
We wouldn't be able to fool the
genuinely funny people,
boredom.
And I think also just the,
uh,
there's such an intense psychic pain
just being alive and all this stuff
going down on,
around you and on top of you and it's
suffocating.
You know,
humor is released.
It,
it's,
it is joyful.
You know,
it's like sex,
but you can have it more often.
Um,
it,
yeah,
it's like cheap sex.
It's like,
it's,
you can do it all the time,
so,
okay.
You know,
I don't know that it's sort of a cliche.
They have a funny rabbi,
you know,
every rabbi thinks he's pretty
hilarious.
Um,
or at least they do nowadays.
And the old days,
I think they thought they were pretty
serious.
Uh,
you know,
I don't know,
I could wax philosophical and say,
well,
there's,
you know,
comedy and religion or about some sort
of aspiration or something higher or do
you know,
to elevate us?
And when we laugh,
you know,
our souls become bigger.
But I don't think so.
Um,
I think,
I think rabbis are smart people and I
think smart people tend to be funny.
So maybe that's the connection,
by the way.
I should have been drinking coffee,
but,
uh,
I don't if there's any connection
whatsoever.
Um,
you know,
I think there must be some connection
between religion and comedy because a
while,
because the people I know in comedy are
either pretty religious or,
and that's the minority,
or is there a swing the other way
completely and are rabidly atheistic.
So,
uh,
maybe,
um,
there's some emotional switch that gets
clicked on either way.
That's a good question.
Uh,
comedy,
it's a lot more self aware than they
used to be.
The audience as a lot more self aware
of,
uh,
you know,
we're not,
you're not just making jokes necessarily
anymore.
You're making jokes on jokes and your
jokes have reference to other jokes.
And,
uh,
it might have been in the old days,
the only other people in the comedy
business would know these things.
But now everyone's,
we've got such a vast cultural,
uh,
backlog on DVD and everything that
everyone knows,
every Monte Python sketch and everyone
knows this and that,
that,
that we're all kind of,
we and the audience are making
references to,
uh,
and,
and winking at them from things that are
40 years old.
And that said,
I,
and comedy probably,
it hasn't changed as much as we think it
has either.
You know what I mean?
That,
that,
that can say,
okay,
well we all have that reference point,
but it's probably an a in a small way,
not that big a deal.
And,
and,
um,
okay.
Wow.
That's a good question because I,
I would say we still laugh at slapstick
and,
but we don't as much,
you know,
and it would be very hard for,
um,
you know,
to get away with something as like,
it's primitive.
It was like an early sixties Jerry Lewis
movie right now.
You just,
you know,
even the kids aren't laughing at that
anymore.
You've got Mr. Bean like,
and that's nice and that's nice slap
stick and,
but it's somehow,
it seems more sophisticated,
but that,
that,
that I might just be,
because it's more modern style.
Uh,
it used to be,
you know,
if he lived in a village and didn't have
tv and a clown came through,
he said that it was the funniest God,
anything you'd ever seen in your life.
You know,
he'd be fell on this,
but amazing.
If you've got,
you know,
eight hours of TV every day and you can
see amazing,
you know,
you can see Marcel Marceau and you can
see,
uh,
Lenny Bruce,
he can see whatever,
whatever,
you know,
the exposure makes you more of a,
I'm a critic.
You know,
if you've only been peanut butter and
jelly sandwiches all your life,
you think those are pretty great.
But you know,
once you taste the caviar,
forget about peanut butter.
I don't know if there's a,
there's an awful lot of it being
produced.
Um,
I think what we're doing now,
you know,
is an area where we're going to see a
lot of comedy produced just in smaller,
uh,
it just with the Internet,
for the power of giving the people just
to produce things.
I mean,
uh,
we're going to see things on youtube,
you know,
we're going to see if people have a
funny idea and shoot it on their dv
camera and get it out there that
afternoon.
Um,
okay.
But people are always also going to want
to see bigger,
you know,
more expensive things.
They're always gonna want to see
sitcoms,
I think,
or a big funny movies that you wanna see
something nice,
you know,
it's like,
okay,
Youtube,
that was a funny video that guy made,
you know?
But I want to,
I want a compelling story to,
you know,
people like stories.
We've,
we've always liked stories.
Uh,
so I,
I don't,
I don't think comedy is going to change
a,
okay.
Here.
I don't think the forum comedy takes,
there's going to be all that different
in the future.
Um,
now,
you know,
I don't know which way the world's going
to go,
but if,
you know,
the world gets darker than the comedy
will probably become darker,
more violent.
Um,
we might be seeing some of that now.
Okay.
No,
I don't,
I tend not to watch any comedy,
otherwise it would be my whole life.
And also,
you know,
like,
it's so critical.
It's impossible just to watch anything
and enjoy it,
you know?
So I,
I tend to keep away from it as much as
possible.
Okay.
I Dunno.
I,
I think it's changing it for,
it's changing it.
There's really no telling.
Yeah,
it's better.
It's nice to be able to have a DVD of
funny stuff and,
you know,
it's nice to be able to go on Youtube
and watch the funny guys.
Um,
but yeah,
I saw these 20 guys doing a David Blaine
impression the other day.
That was funny.
You know,
I got to watch that.
Now.
I don't have to see it anymore,
you know,
but it's out there that are Kelly
trapped in the closet.
Like that's all great stuff and it's
there.
And um,
so that's all for the good.
Um,
as you know,
it isn't strictly about computers,
but you know,
as,
as a visual agent,
no written comedy is nonexistent.
You know,
there's a couple of pages in the front
of the New Yorker and that's really it.
So that's kind of sad.
Um,
but you know,
there's plenty to read if you want to.
I can certainly make fun of my people.
Um,
and other Cantu,
I mean it's,
I feel like I'm a nine,
but I think as a Jew is sort of a
specific case because there are a lot of
Jewish writers and we tend to go to the
Jew,
well,
a lot in comedy and bounced that it's
really easy.
And I don't love that.
I think it's a little too easy.
Um,
you know,
ethnically at El,
I think you'll find a lot of copywriters
are Jewish and a lot her Irish.
Uh,
and I,
I'm not sure why those two streams sort
of came together,
but you know,
it's,
uh,
we tend to get along so it's nice.
Um,
can
I think some Jewish jokes are very funny
and I think others are,
you know,
are just at,
or just it,
just saying the word Jew and expecting a
laugh,
you know,
and,
and uh,
that's easy.
At first the other ethnicities go,
um,
I don't feel like anything should be out
of bounds,
you know,
I,
I just,
you know,
I'm stridently,
First Amendment,
struggling second amendment to have.
I like all those amendments,
you know,
and uh,
and then again,
that said,
if you say something offensive,
you know,
you can expect to get your ass kicked.
You know,
you should have the right to say it
though.
I think everyone self sensors,
I mean,
you think awful things,
you,
I'm sure you're thinking the awful
things right now,
but you know,
we all think terrible,
terrible,
terrible things.
Uh,
so sometimes the terrible things,
I think our jokes and uh,
so I don't always say this out loud.
I'm actually,
I probably self censor a lot less than a
lot of people and I have certainly said
some terrible things,
which I regret,
but that's okay.
Yes.
I can't say I think about,
and again,
it's,
you know,
I would ask you,
uh,
or I'd ask anyone,
does it,
is it easier for them to self censor?
Sometimes you know,
you,
you walk around saying,
I'm censoring myself right now.
No,
but you know,
like,
uh,
you aren't telling every beautiful woman
how much you would like to have sex with
her reverie.
Attractive man.
The same thing.
If,
if you find both of them equally
attractive,
you know,
um,
it has,
it become easier to sell.
I don't know.
I guess when you were a kid,
you know,
you say anything you want.
Uh,
I'm an adult now.
I don't,
um,
I,
I would say it's not any different for a
comedy writer or a writer in general
than it is for anyone else.
I think we are afforded more freedom.
I think I don't,
I don't think writers and Comedians
don't have to censor as much.
I think,
you know,
we're given that latitude.
We don't want to use it that level.
We have it.
Okay.